hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
what we're going to talk about in this
video is how to use the chain rule when
you're taking the derivative so you're
probably just getting into calculus and
you're starting to learn some of these
different techniques like the product
rule quotient rule and then along comes
the chain rule so that's what we're
going to talk about in this video so
what the chain rule is it's like a
composition of functions what you're
doing is essentially you're taking the
derivative of the outer function and
then you're multiplying it by the
derivative of the inner function so I'll
show you what I mean in this first
example and then I'll show you some
shortcuts just how to go ahead and do it
you know more quickly so in this first
example we've got y equals 3x minus 2
cubed so what we're going to do is we're
going to do a u-substitution we're just
going to say u equals 3x minus 2 so I'm
just going to write that down here u
equals 3x minus 2 and I'm going to take
the derivative of U with respect to X D
u DX and that's just going to equal 3
because the derivative of negative 2 is
0 and the derivative of 3x you can do
the power rule you're just going to get
3 now the next thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to rewrite this I'm going to
write this as y equals u cubed okay
because we replace 3x minus 2 with you
and I'm going to take the derivative now
so dy/dx equals I'm sorry dy D u we're
taking the derivative Y with respect to
u the variable u here and we get 3 u
squared ok because we're bringing down
the 3 and we're subtracting 1 from the
exponent so you're with me so far ok but
now we're going to do is we're gonna put
these together so we've got dy D u the
derivative of Y with respect to U and
we're gonna multiply that by the
derivative of U with respect to X ok so
dy to u we got 3 u squared D u DX we've
got 3 okay so we can see we're getting 9
u squared ok so 9 u squared but what
does u equal 3x minus 2 right so that
comes out to 9 times 3x minus 2 the
quantity squared now that was kind of a
long process I think you'll agree and
as you do this you know more and more
you're just going to do the shortcut I'm
going to show you right here you're
going to realize that you're taking a
quantity to a power so you're just going
to say well let me just do the power
rule and what you do is you take the
exponent you bring it down in front and
you subtract one so that's going to look
like this
so you've got Y Prime the derivative y
equals three times 3x minus two squares
all I do is bring down the three I
subtracted one from the exponent then
you're gonna want to take the derivative
of the inside the derivative of 3x minus
2 is 3 so you can see 3 times 3 gives
you 9 and then 3 X minus 2 squared and
that's your derivative so you can see
that was a lot faster let's take a look
at a couple more examples and you'll get
a hang of how this works so in this one
here you can see we've got the cosine
and we know that the derivative of
cosine is negative sine so this is going
to be negative sine of 2x but we have to
take the derivative of the inside now so
derivative of 2x is just 2 so I'm gonna
say times 2 and we could just rewrite
this a little bit neater negative 2 sine
2x like so okay so here with me so far
let's look at a couple more examples
this one here same thing we're raising
this quantity to a power we're gonna use
the power rule I bring the 4 down in
front so we have Y prime equals 4 2x
minus 5 okay over 3x squared we're going
to subtract 1 from the exponent okay so
here with me so far but then we have to
take the derivative of the inside and
you can see that we have a quotient so
we have to do the quotient rule and the
quotient rule you can remember this
little rhyme I'm sure you learned it
already but it's a low D high minus high
D low over the square of what's below so
we're gonna be multiplying by low 3 x
squared d hi derivative of 2x minus 5 is
2 minus hi 2x minus 5 D low the
derivative of 3x squared is 6x over the
square of what's below so that's 3x
squared squared and then you can go
ahead and simplify that further but for
right now I'm just gonna leave it like
that so just a quick note we brought
down the power we subtracted 1 that's
the power rule so that was a derivative
of the outside that was the power
function
then we have to take the derivative the
inside but since it was a quotient we
had to do the quotient rule last example
this is a another trig one y equals
tangent squared of 3x and I just want to
give you a little hint you can think of
this as tangent of 3x or just rewrite it
like this the quantity squared so I'm
said of putting the two here I think
sometimes students find it a little bit
confusing you can write it over here
just think of the whole thing as being
squared treat this like a power function
you're going to bring that two down in
front so y prime equals two tangent of
3x okay to the first because we're
subtracting one the derivative inside so
the derivative of tangent is secant
squared so we have secant squared of 3x
and then the derivative of the inside
again
okay them innermost part the derivative
of 3x is 3 so times 3 and then you can
simplify that and rearrange it a little
bit you know more to kind of make it
neater by multiplying the two into 3 and
you know kind of cleaning up a little
bit but that's the idea you take the
derivative the outside times the dhruv
of the inside and you keep working your
way in you might have to do that three
or four or five times even but usually
it's just maybe two or three at the most
so I hope you benefited from this video
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
check out some of my other past videos
and I'll see you in the future videos
I'll talk to you soon